former Secretary of State Condoleezza
Rice is drawing on her government
experience to help other leaders
understand today's political landscape
around the world her new book is called
political risk how businesses and
organizations can anticipate global
insecurity
it is co-authored by fellow Stanford
professor Amy zegart
we welcome Secretary Rice back to studio
57 good morning good morning let's talk
first about North Korea president Trump
has described North Korea's leader
yesterday as very open and very
straightforward so far
do you believe Kim jong-un will ever
abandon his nuclear weapons program
well the North Koreans have made a lot
of promises about denuclearization I
think I may have been the last Secretary
of State to actually negotiate with
North Koreans back in 2007 2008
2000-2009 and they're under pressure as
they were then they have a tendency when
they're under pressure under sanctions
to come to the table to go on a kind of
charm offensive in fact I think
secretary Tillison actually former
secretary Tillison actually deserves a
lot of credit for putting together a
pretty tough isolation campaign one of
the things that wasn't noticed about 20
countries expelled North Korean workers
that meant hard currency going back to
the regime was cut off the regime was
starting to run out of military parts so
they come to the table now the question
is are they serious I would have only
three admonitions for the administration
the first is this could be an opening
this is the first time we've dealt this
directly I was impressed with Secretary
of Secretary Pompeo then CIA director
Pompeo getting to Pyongyang and none of
us knew that's pretty amazing and then
so we're negotiating directly that's
good but the three admonitions don't
forget that there are other interested
parties for instance Japan has very
important interests here secondly take
it one step at a time it's fine to talk
about a peace treaty on the Korean
Peninsula in fact we talked about a
peace treaty that should be the ultimate
goal but Gulf step-by-step make sure
there's good verification of everything
the North Koreans are doing and keep
your eye on the prize of being
because what we want to do is stop them
short of threatening the American
homeland and then finally remember the
nature of this regime this is a regime
that murdered an American citizen just a
year ago this is a regime where the
leader ganda are killed his half-brother
in Malaysia using VX gas it's a brutal
regime a secretive regime I have no
problem with negotiating with them but
beware we talked about the inspections
regime with the Iran deal what for you
is the most important part of an
inspections regime if there is a deal
one day to make sure that they don't
cheat and and what should people be
looking for well the most important
thing about an inspection regime with a
country that you know has cheated in the
past is what I would call snap
inspections meaning that you can go
anywhere any time that you wish to send
inspectors there these regimes are very
good at for instance cleaning up a site
after they've been notified that you
want to look at that site and so they
tend to list their known sites but hide
other sites and so you have to be able
to go anywhere anytime but let me just
say getting inspectors on the ground can
make a difference and I hope that one of
the first steps in these North Korean
negotiations would be to get inspectors
International Atomic Energy Agency
expect errs on the ground because our
intelligence about North Korea is not
very good being on the ground with
experienced people you pick up things
that you wouldn't be able to pick up
through other means we talked about the
president and the Iran deal and the fact
that he may potentially withdraw from
that how could how might that affect
negotiations with North Korea well some
have said the North Koreans will then
think that America's not trustworthy
right but this would be a little bit the
the pot calling the kettle black right I
mean the North Koreans saying Americans
aren't trustworthy I'm not too worried
about that so you don't think I I don't
really think that this would be an issue
the North Koreans are going to negotiate
if they negotiate because it's in their
interest to do so
because they're under pressure
what has happened with Iran I think
isn't the issue it might be a little bit
of an object lesson though for Kim
jong-un that we negotiated with Moammar
Qaddafi and Gadhafi didn't end up so
well like I think that maybe more in his
memory bank than what we do with Iran in
your book you call the the landscape the
most complex security environment in
modern history how have those political
risks evolved since you were Secretary
of State and as President Trump made it
that are worse well there's there's no
doubt that the sources of political risk
are multiplying if one thinks about the
old days we worried about if you're a
business they're gonna expropriate my
property Cuba or they're like not so
much a risk anymore but who would have
thought that one of the big risks would
be the use of social media platforms for
a great power behaving badly the
Russians to interfere in our elections
that's one of the new ways in which
technology matters when you think about
the risk that comes from somebody simply
having a cellphone and seeing a bad
incident in your store when you think
about long supply chains and what trade
wars or tariffs could do to supply
chains that for instance are in Canada
or in Mexico the day after 9/11 we close
the border with Canada within three days
nobody could make a car because the
supply chain was in Canada when you
start threatening trade wars you
threaten things like supply chains so I
think the sources of political risk are
multiplying anyway but anything that
adds to that uncertainty like talk
around tariffs and trade wars certainly
increases that uncertainty for
businesses well that brings us then to
this president usually in the in the
global order after the second world war
the United States was the stable slow
moving rock upon which people could
depend we have a highly improvisational
president who gets some credit for North
Korea from and he knows that critics
alike however that sense of
improvisation trade where here maybe not
a trade war there you talked about
alliance management there have been some
bruised feelings with alliances how much
has he contributed to this
risk and how do you how do you manage
against that well there's certainly a
sense that there's volatility in the
American political landscape that is
unusual in our history but I wouldn't
overstate it to the point that well this
president is therefore the source of
political risk I think that's unfair you
know the fact is these sources of
political risk have been multiplying for
some time now
when terrorism became an issue it meant
that as we heartened airports for
instance if you were in the hospitality
industry all of a sudden you were a soft
target the tear the risks that come from
cyber security have been multiplying for
some time so yes it's the United States
is always better for people when we're
stable and steady and so forth but these
sources of political risk have been
multiplying for a long time I wonder as
someone who has been in the war room how
critical is it for a president to be
surrounded with or have access to
advisors who have opposing points of
view it's absolutely critical that the
president here opposing points of view
it can be very easy in that room the
Situation Room for everyone to start
reinforcing each other and so the
president needs to be able to hear no
mr. president that's that's not right
he needs also to be able to hear it and
away from his advisors that it doesn't
appear with all due respect to the media
on the front page of the New York Times
well dude is that a concern for you
given this president and the structure
of his career well it's a concern for me
because it looks to me that some of the
constraints some of the barriers that
people felt about being in the White
House and keeping that within the cone
that some of that has broken down but
that said this is a different president
he's never been in government before
it's the first time that we've actually
elected somebody whose first job in
government was president United States
and so we had to expect that there would
be some differences he still has many
very good people around him but I hope
going into this very important set of
negotiations with North Korea that
you're going to see a disciplined
process because the
Koreans are masters at taking advantage
of loopholes and weaknesses and so I'm
able Eve that Secretary of pompei looks
like he's going about it in the right
way but this is going to take real
discipline ask you one question about
political risk and this kind of this
world in which everybody's
interconnected and things are more
threatening than ever make the case or
not for diplomacy in such a world where
you can have problems break out at any
moment is that connectivity should
America reach out to the world or
withdraw America has to reach out to the
world
we have been since the end of World War
two the guardians of a system that has
served everybody really very well a
prosperous international economy that
was not zero-sum game before World War
Two in World War one people were
engaging in beggar-thy-neighbor trading
policies currency manipulation conflict
over resources we came along and said
you know this can be a positive sum game
where everybody wins lifted hundreds of
millions of people out of poverty the
international economy worked we
advocated for democracy we believed in a
democratic peace we rebuilt Germany and
Japan as great democracies believing
that they could be strong as long as
they were democratic it works splendidly
and we protected it with American
military power and American attention to
values and I hope that we're going to
hear more about that because it's worked
pretty well for the world and it's
worked pretty well for us I know it
hasn't worked for every single corner of
America and there the president is right
we have to look at what's happening to
our fellow citizens who can't read have
anymore can't have any more kids who go
to college get lots of debt and no
usable job skills you can't have any
more 35 year olds who can't be retrained
so he is right to focus on that aspect
of America that people have to be able
to benefit from the American dream but
my goodness I can't think of a better
guardian of an international system
built on our values and our interest
than the United States of America here's
you to just about the state of the white
house because you worked with george w
bush
closely and that one house there were
reports last night that the president's
chief of staff has called the president
an idiot
that his former Secretary of State at
the time Tillerson who you know well
called him a [ __ ] what does that say
about how this White House is being
operated well it says something about
people who would go out and say those
things about conversations that they did
or did not hear within the White House
that's that breakdown of discipline it's
been coming for a while you know it's
not just this administration that's had
damaging leaks but you know the the
level of comedy in a White House you
know these jobs are hard enough you
don't need to get up in the morning and
read in the newspaper that somebody is
saying something about the president
whatever you may think about the
president I've had my disagreements with
this president but he and I have many
but he is President of the United States
let's respect the office because it's
extremely important that the the White
House function as a unit secretary rice
thank you so much the new book political
risk how businesses and organizations
can anticipate global insecurity is on
sale today